today on the matt wall show the biden
administration has announced its plan to
get rid of all traffic accidents and
traffic deaths reduce it to zero now
after failing to shut down kovid they
will now attempt to prevent anyone from
ever dying of anything ever again also
joe biden officially begins his search
for a new supreme court justice he
promises it will be a thorough search
and he'll consider a diverse selection
of potential nominees as long as they
are black female and liberal the
greatest female jeopardy contestant of
all time who's actually male finally
loses and a writer wins praise from the
left were for publicly announcing that
she doesn't like being a mother and
finally in our daily cancellation a phd
student attempts to school me on the
topic of sex and gender we'll see how
she did today all of that and more today
on the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
well ladies i know valentine's day is
just around the corner and you're
starting to think about what you could
get your man to represent how much you
love him and if you're thinking that oh
i don't have to get the man anything for
valentine's day think again okay so love
is a two-way street so take it for me
the popular saying the way to his heart
is through his stomach is true so why
not get your bow some delicious and high
quality meat with daily wires exclusive
meat company good ranchers not only
would you be getting the love of your
life a great gift but you would also be
supporting small american farmers and
ranches who are currently fighting to
stay in business plus to sweeten the
deal use my code walsh and you'll be get
you'll get 30 off your order there's
something for everybody t-bones rib eyes
gourmet burgers so much more and um
you're guaranteed to get your loved ones
some meat that they will be grateful for
so visit goodranchers.com
walsh or use codewalls to check out to
get 30 off any one of their many boxes
there's a lot to choose from everything
they sell is truly top notch and you
really have to try it to believe it so
visit goodranchers.comwalls today to
save 30 on your new favorite steak start
the year with good ranchers american
meat delivered
so there are two basic facts about
government uh one is that whenever it
fails at something its solution for its
own failure is always to do exactly what
it was already doing except to do it
more and more expensively the second is
that most bureaucrats are useless and
the most useless ones are often the ones
who do the most and do it loudest
because they feel the great compulsion
to justify their own existence which
means they'll always look for things to
do even if those things don't need to be
done or if doing them would cause more
problems than it solves
there are other important realities of
government in modern times but those are
the two facts i think which
must be kept always in mind and both of
them are prominently on display in this
story
pete budage a profoundly useless man in
the useless position of transportation
secretary is on a mission to convince
the public that his job is significant
so after returning from his three-month
paternity vacation he first set out to
cure racism by destroying any racist
roads or bridges that he could find it
was never exactly clear how he would
identify the racist infrastructure but
he huddled with a team of diversity
specialists and they figured it out
somehow their plan did not involve
repainting all of the streets white
instead of black
so that still you know now every time
you drive down the street you're
literally trampling upon blackness
which is deeply traumatizing to black
americans and confusing to children by
the way in fact a few weeks ago my
daughter asked me we were in the car and
she said daddy why are all the roads
black
and i looked at her and i said because
everyone is racist sweetie
i hoped i would never have to have that
conversation but i did
at any rate buddhagige
did something or other about the racist
roads i don't know what and now he's
moved on to his next project which is uh
which is even more ambitious
he has now declared that he will reduce
traffic deaths to zero
now the government promised to shut down
kovid and ensured that nobody would ever
die from a virus again and having failed
at that in spectacular fashion they will
now embark on a project to ensure that
nobody dies of anything else ever again
we can be sure that they'll succeed in
that arena about as much as they
succeeded with covid here's budage
announcing the plan listen
another thing that it's going to take in
order to change the trajectory of
roadway safety in this country is a
single ambitious shared goal and today
we commit that our goal is this
zero
our goal is zero deaths
a country where one day nobody has to
say goodbye to a loved one because
of a traffic crash
understand the scale of the challenge
and the ambition represented by that
goal and i understand that we may not
get there during my tenure as secretary
but the decision to commit to that goal
in a serious way at a national level
changes the way cities and towns design
roads it changes the ways companies
build cars it changes the way people
drive them
oh yeah it certainly would change all
those things yes zero traffic accidents
zero deaths
now some have argued that there's
nothing wrong with this goal this is
just the ideal they say yes of course we
won't ever actually abolish traffic
accidents completely but we should at
least try they say
a quarterback will never have a 100
completion percentage across the whole
season but he still tries to complete
every throw
why can't we do the same thing with this
well i'll tell you why
those in charge of public policy
have to engage in risk assessment and
risk management
we also have to do this on an individual
personal level
but risk management means that you're
managing the risk
which means the risk is there the risk
is there you're simply taking steps to
to negate it within reason
every human activity carries risk the
risk is inherent
flying is very safe generally but there
are still many risks
why are there risks well because you're
35 000 feet in the sky the risk is
always that you're going to come down
from the sky in a non-ideal manner let's
say you can manage that risk but to
erase the risk to make it so that there
is no risk to go from risk management to
risk abolition
is to effectively abolish the activity
itself the only way to make sure that
nobody ever dies in a plane crash is to
make sure that nobody ever flies on a
plane
if you're allowing people to fly on the
plane you're allowing some amount of
risk
you are saying by allowing people to get
on planes you are saying
it's okay
that some people are going to die doing
this
because if it's not okay at all
then nobody should be allowed to do it
your risk tolerance cannot be zero
the only way to not take any risk when
doing something is to not do it
so let's think about what zero risk or
near zero risk driving would look like
first of all highways are gone
they're gone no more highways as long as
people are driving 60 miles an hour
there are going to be fatal car crashes
a national speed limit of 25 miles an
hour would have to be established and
that's just the starting point also the
driving age would have to be raised to
at least 25 which is the age when the
prefrontal cortex is fully developed and
you know you're starting to think a
little bit more rationally and thus
you're a better driver but if you're
going to go for zero deaths then really
you want to raise it to probably 30
maybe 35
so i would just be coming off my
learner's permit right now
next all forms of discrete distraction
in the vehicle must be outlawed no more
drive-throughs close them all
eating while driving is distracting
no more driving with other people in the
car especially kids
can't have them in the car with you
um we'd have to outlaw cell phones
entirely because that's the only way to
ensure that nobody has them in their car
also we're going to need licenses to be
renewed and the driver's test to be
retaken at least once a year probably
every six months
for the rest of your life
that's just the starting point
more such measures would need to be put
in place but anything less than these
measures would mean that thousands of
people are still going to die behind the
wheel
and even with these measures or any
other you can dream up
still there are going to be fatalities
the only way to really get rid of them
is to get rid of driving
along with all other forms of
transportation faster than walking
but even walking could potentially kill
you
you know you could fall down the steps
you gotta get rid of all the steps too
later in his speech budajid said quote
we will work with every level of
government and industry to deliver
results because every driver passenger
and pedestrian should be certain that
they're going to arrive at their
destination safely every time
really
certain
we now have the right of to be certain
of our safety even while engaging in
inherently risky activities
you might as well say that that every
person eating food should be certain
that they won't choke
what does it even mean to say that
unless you want to eat through a feeding
tube for the rest of your life you can
never be certain that you won't joke
in fact contrary to buddha jig
we should not be certain of our safety
in the car or in any area of life
because the only way to achieve that
certitude is either to delude ourselves
or to stop living
now you know this stuff about zero car
accident fatalities it may seem like the
silly ramblings of a bureaucrat with the
mental acuity of a carrot and it is in
one sense but that's not all it is
now if i'd heard something like this
three years ago
i may have laughed it off and just said
ah it's ridiculous
but things have changed in recent times
and many americans have shown a profound
willingness to go to extraordinary
lengths
to embrace previously unimaginable forms
of tyranny in order to feel protected
from even the smallest risk of harm or
death
millions of parents have been willing
even to to ruin their children's lives
cause significant emotional and
psychological damage on purpose
knowingly
all in the pursuit of this same futile
goal
and you know the government has noticed
this
that's another that's another thing we
can know about government
when the people tolerate any form of
tyranny tyranny they take note
and they say oh you're okay with that
are you well here's some more
and so now we're going to see
one plan after another
to address one crisis after another you
know you notice how we see described it
as a crisis
car accidents are a crisis
that's not a crisis
there have always been car accidents as
long as there have been highways
and even before that
it's not a crisis it's just life
and death
which is a part of life
but there's going to be one crisis after
another
to protect us from the risk of one form
of death after another
and though none of these plans will be
successful obviously or will even have
the chance of being successful
they will come at the cost of liberty
and dignity
a price that many people in this country
have shown themselves
tragically willing to pay
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
i've been doing a lot of dating and
marriage advice on this show recently
for whatever reason so here's some more
advice um here's a top-notch gift ideas
this time i'm speaking to the men in the
audience guys it's time to get your lady
something practical that you know she
will absolutely love your gal probably
has enough jewelry
i mean they can never really have enough
jewelry but you know and chocolates will
be gone within a day so get something
that lasts cleaning supplies
but don't get it from just any standard
unhealthy brand that will reek of
chemicals you want to get cleaning
supplies with with our partner naturally
it's clean naturally it's clean is
dedicated to providing the most
effective cleaning products for for your
home while reducing your spending your
waste and harmful chemicals in your home
their safer chemistry solutions utilize
nature's powerful plant-based enzymes to
clean every area of your home from the
bathroom to your hardwood floors to your
kitchen doesn't it sound like something
you know that your special someone will
love listen
fellas ladies love to clean it's the
most it's the thing they enjoy most in
life and so give them the opportunity to
do it and they're going to find it to be
very romantic also for valentine's day
so try naturally it's clean now and get
something that you know will win your
ladies heart just when you do this don't
blame me remember this is from you right
now my listeners can get their get their
hands on the daily wire essential kit
stocked with four essential products for
fifteen percent off simply visit
naturalistclean.com and use promo code
matt to save an additional 15 off your
order you know the thing about kids is
uh
as as everyone knows of course they hate
going to bed and
it's always a it's always a struggle
especially in my heart i don't know how
it is for most parents but
in my house bedtimes is just to keep
them in the room at night when you put
them down and they're always looking for
reasons to come out um and so that's
that's the challenges especially the
case with my with my daughter i mean
it's kind of you have like two forms
with kids there's there's two versions
of this there are the kids so you put
them to bed and they're bouncing off the
walls for 30 minutes and they just fall
asleep that's that's the boys and then
there's my daughter's kind of quiet but
she'll stay up for like three hours and
she'll keep trying to find reasons to
come out and she gets kind of creative
with it sometimes so yesterday last
night it was like 10 30 at night
and she comes uh barreling out of her
room
and uh she she said mommy dad i gotta
tell you something and i thought it was
like an emergency something i don't know
what it was i got to tell you something
and said okay what is it
did you know that snails have 15 000
teeth
and also dolphins have more teeth than
sharks
no i didn't know that
thank you for the update
i'll make sure to keep that in mind now
please go to bed
and then later i went googled it and
it's actually true snails have 15 000
teeth
learn something new every day
from your kids at 10 30 at night all
right so joe biden officially announced
the supreme court vacancy yesterday and
after it was
it was announced unofficially
um with justice breyer's
apparently not his consent originally at
least at least the announcement was not
with his consent so they they kind of
gave him the nudge and said hey we're
announcing your retirement um
congratulations you're retiring i guess
you're learning about it too at the same
time everybody else's so joe biden
officially announced it yesterday he uh
addressed the nation and once again
reiterated his pledge to forbid
any white man from taking the position
listen
our process is going to be rigorous
i will select the nominee
worthy of justice briar's legacy of
excellence and decency
while i've been studying candidates
backgrounds and writings
i've made no decision except one
the person i will nominate will be
someone with extraordinary
qualifications
character
experience and integrity
and that person will be the first black
woman ever nominated to united states
supreme court
it's long overdue in my view
it's going to be a thorough process and
he's going to look at all the candidates
as long as they're the same race
and they're all female
and of course they're all on the far
left
so with a thorough and rigorous
uh process that will involve
um you know about like four four
potential nominees
that's what passes for that's a it's not
only a rigorous process it's also it's
also a diverse
um process you know there was this like
this
concept of diversity
and there was a for for a while i used
to say
that kind of the democrat notion of
diversity when they say diverse
diversity what they what they really
have in mind
are a bunch of people
who look different and have different
skin pigments uh get different shades of
skin
a bunch of people all in a room
saying the same thing speaking in unison
with the same exact beliefs
that was i used to think that that's
that's their idea of diversity
where everybody everybody looks
different at least skin deep but they
all think exactly the same way
because there's rigorous
uh intellectual conformity on the left
but now now that's not even true
i think that's probably giving them too
much credit
because now diverse a diverse group or
diversity that means a bunch of people
in a room who all look the same and also
think the same way
because as we've talked about diversity
now is code for
not white
that's that's how they could get away
with like talking about an individual
person and saying
whenever they whenever they select
whichever black woman it's going to be
whichever liberal far left black woman
is going to be
they're going to say this is our this is
a diverse selection well how could a a
single person be diverse
that only makes sense when you
understand that by diverse they mean
non-white so every time you hear that
just sub in non-white and all of a
sudden
the sentence kind of makes sense
um
but there is this this kind of awkward
reality for people on the left when they
want to make a big deal out of this oh
we're going to get a we're going to need
a black nominee
a black female nominee well we've
already we've already had female court
uh justices on the court and there's
currently a black justice on the court
does he not count well as the ladies of
the view agreed yesterday um in fact he
does not count no
susan collins well he should have the
votes considering the uneven kind of uh
court we have right now it's so
important that this is happening on in a
time where we can get another liberal
and of course the representation more
than anything you pointed out first
black woman there's only been two black
men in it
that those numbers are a little shocking
and one doesn't really represent the
black community no of course
but my my whole point is that but in
addition to additional diversity i think
is important that i just noticed as we
talked about this is whenever they talk
about a potential justice we talk about
the ivy league
he doesn't represent the black community
by the way the the woman talking right
there is is she she's supposed to be con
i think she's supposed to be the
conservative on am i am i wrong is she
supposed to be the conservative
representative on the view
um
but clarence thomas she she represents
conservatism i guess that lady but
clarence thomas does not he's not
representative of of black people like
what does that even mean to begin with
doesn't represent black it's a
is that your your job as a as a as a
black man is to constantly represent
are you not an individual
do you not have your own identity
everything you do has to represent and
represent in what way
is there some established consensus
among all black people about what uh
what they all are supposed to think and
feel
and so your job as a black man is to
never think or feel anything outside of
that
just removing the individual identity
from people that's another part
of the diversity plan on the left
all right um here's another diverse
person uh from the new york post amy
schneider's jeopardy winning streak has
finally come to an end last week the 42
year old made history when and i'm
reading i'm just reading the language
from this article um otherwise
i wouldn't be choosing this language
myself last week the 42 year old made
history when she
won her
39th game and became number two on the
game show's consecutive win lease
winning list and the winningest woman of
all time but her time at the top ended
wednesday when she lost to uh ron tulsma
a librarian from chicago
um
and
lots of jokes can be made here and have
already been made so i'm late to it
saying maybe the final category was what
is a woman it wasn't the final category
was countries of the world
and um and then uh now schneider trails
only ken jennings
74 wins on the long-running game shows
consecutive wins list
but she
quote unquote is now uh the the number
one champion
woman contestant of all time
and the second place
uh woman
trying to find her on here there's a
quote maybe i cut it off the second
place woman who's really the first woman
she she the actual she congratulated the
fake she
for you know supplanting her as the the
top female jeopardy contestant of all
time
because that's what she has to do
do you think the the woman who actually
is the best female jeopardy contest of
all time you think she's happy about
this
that her place has been taken from her
by a man
no but she has to pretend that way
so now she's the top uh uh now she's
number two and and the man is number one
for for female
contestants
and
you know i have to just complain about
this again because the new york post
i guess would consider itself to be a
just kind of mainstream media outlet
but i've read
plenty of articles in supposedly
conservative outlets about
this story about amy schneider
and
in the vast majority of them
even these conservative outlets are
using the preferred pronoun for
amy schneider for calling a man a woman
and they do this as i've complained
about many times
they do this many of these conservative
outlets even while pretending to oppose
this
they'll report on leah thomas over at
university of pennsylvania crushing the
female competition
and report on it in a negative way like
this is a bad thing
female sports are being destroyed by
this everything else
and yet they'll still use the preferred
pronoun
i've read plenty of commentary pieces by
conservatives saying this is terrible
females women's sports are under attack
because of people like leah thomas
she is crushing the competition well do
you see you've just destroyed your
argument
you've you've surrendered the point it's
over now
the moment you agree
with the language you choose to use the
moment that you agree that this in fact
is a woman
it's what is what are you arguing about
just
immense cowardice even among
conservatives
and i i use that i use that phrase
conservative uh very very loosely i
think we need to put we need to put
scare quotes around that like we do
around she when talking about amy
schneider or leah thomas
because this is not just compromising
with the left this is not you
there's plenty of that has happened
in recent years
but this is you adopting far far left
radical ideas
and not just far left radical ideas but
far left radical ideas about basic facts
of existence
you are you are adopting their premise
in the most extreme ways
about basic facts of reality the moment
you do that you're on their side i don't
care what else you have to say
i don't care what your other positions
are
i would go so far as to say i don't you
could be strongly in favor of of uh gun
rights you could be anti-immigration
you don't like
high taxes small government all that
kind of stuff
you can even call yourself pro-life
and go to the march for life
but if you're going to start calling a
man a woman
then you're on the left
because you have agreed with their
version of reality
and it's a version of reality where you
know all of their other
ideological points
sprout from that this is this is the
root here
and everything else is a branch from
that root
because leftism is all about relativism
it's the worship of the self
that's why this gender stuff is so
important to them
because they want to establish
that reality itself is subject to an
individual's wins if i feel a certain
way i can change reality
reality will change itself according to
my whims
if you agree with that
by calling a man a woman because that's
what they want to be called
then you've given up the whole game
you are in no
coherent way a conservative at that
point
what are you conserving
i think there's there are many things
that need to be conserved in this
culture but to begin with we have to
conserve reality if we're not conserving
that then
then we lose everything
so you can't say okay i'll give up
reality but i really care about gun
rights
well good for you
go to antifa meeting and tell them about
that
you're not on our side
all right this is a video that i played
for you probably almost probably almost
a year ago and um it's going viral again
for whatever reason
so i want to play it again
because any any any excuse to play this
i think is uh
is worthwhile this is trans affirming dr
johanna olsen kennedy she's very
prominent in her field
this is her talking about
um
performing these surgeries these
mutilation procedures on on kids and
explaining why it's actually perfectly
fine to do and it's all good listen
actually people make life-altering
decisions in adolescence
all the time
all the time and honestly most of them
are good it's just the bad ones that we
talk about
oh my god the cinnamon challenge right i
mean why do we know about it because
it's it's a thing and it's it's not it's
not common like most teenagers aren't
eating cinnamon right but some are and
they're on youtube and that's stupid but
we don't put on youtube the things that
are really good decisions right oh my
gosh my kid took the s18s
not a very exciting after school special
right but so what we do know is that
adolescents actually have the capacity
to make a reasoned logical decision
and here's the other thing about chest
surgery if you want breasts at a later
point in your life you can go and get
them
it's uh i've heard that clip many times
it's
it doesn't get any less horrifying
especially when you consider that this
this is not some fringe
character here
this is a prominent person in this in
this field
of mutilating kids
and what does she say she says uh hey
kit kids kids make responsible decisions
all the time
they take the sats
which is pretty revealing that that's
the example she gives for responsible
decisions made by kids because guess
what
that's not a decision that kids make
their parents make that for them
i took the sats do you think i wanted to
if it were up to me i would not have
taken them
um but my parents said you got to take
the sats
so that is something that is forced on
you as a kid
and even the kids who want to take the
sats or quote unquote want to do
responsible things it's only because
they've been conditioned that way
conditioned in a good way by their
parents
that's part of parenting
is not only telling kids what to do
but but
getting them to a point through moral
formation where they want to do the good
things
but as a parent you say even if you
don't want to do it
even if you're so immature that you
still don't want to do this this very
good thing that's going to help you i
still am going to force you to do it
because it's for your own good
that's what we do with kids
um
but jo dr olson kennedy says that well
kids they can they can make
life-altering decisions
and why well because you can always
reverse it she says which is not true by
the way
you know when you chop off a part of
your body it does you don't get it back
we don't grow it back we're not lizards
regrowing a tail or whatever
so what they can do
and there are a great many
former tra quote unquote trans kids who
are now adults and are looking into
procedures like this because they're
experiencing regret
and we haven't even seen the half of it
yet we haven't even seen a fraction of
what's coming
because the the adults now who are
called d transitioners
who are experiencing regret
um and they transitioned as kids
they were still pretty early in the fad
you know if they transitioned whatever
eight years ago seven eight years ago
right now there is a whole there is an
avalanche
that's coming
because the kids today are the ones who
are growing up you know a five-year-old
today
is among the the the first group of
five-year-olds to grow up in in a in a
culture
where this stuff is fed to them at that
young of an age
and so there'll be a lot more coming in
the future and what they're going to
discover
is that actually you you cannot regrow
you can't you can't reverse that
you know when you go in and you have
your breasts chopped off
that was a part of your body that is now
gone
not getting it back
what they can try to do is refashion
using you know
cosmetic procedures some semblance of
what you had before but it's not going
to be the real thing
but she's she's totally dismissive of
course of any concern that this might be
bad for kids
and if you are not totally opposed to
what you just heard in that clip there
if you are not absolutely diametrically
opposed to it
in every fiber of your being
then you're not on my side i don't know
whose side you're on
this is a you're with us or against this
type of thing
you know when you use the preferred
pronouns that woman there that's who
you're helping you're helping her you're
on her side
you're doing what she wants you to do
all right let's look at this writer
ariana rebellini was the latest woman to
try to earn sympathy and victim points
by
talking about how much she hates her
kids i just wanted to show this to you
um this is also becoming a trend
uh ariane ribollino says i've been
opening up about how i do not enjoy
being a mom
thinking about why i feel so
passionately about talking about it and
i think a large part is my belief that
normalizing celebrating the decision to
be child free
can lead to more communal child care
now
what we're what we're told and
people were criticizing her for this and
rightly so and her justification was hey
i'm just being honest
and uh i i'm just i'm saying what so
many other people think and i'm why
can't i be honest
well i'll tell you why you can't be
quote unquote honest about it first of
all this is a very this is not honesty
it's not honesty at
all because this is you
trying to fool yourself trying to make
yourself feel better
trying to delude yourself
you have this
bad thought
which which which grows from a character
flaw
now look
we all have moments as parents when
um
the parenting job is not very enjoyable
like when it's 10 30 at night and your
kids out there talking about snails
having 15 000 teeth teeth and you just
want them to go to bed so you can hang
out with your spouse right like those
are moments when it's not super
enjoyable in those moments
but if you just hate parenting all
together you hate the whole thing
that is a
that's a character flaw
that's that's a you problem
it's not your kid's fault
and no it's i have news for you it's not
normal
and it shouldn't be
that's not how most parents feel
many parents struggle with aspects of
parenting it can be difficult but most
parents derive a great amount of joy out
of being a parent
and if they could snap their fingers
and reverse the clock and not be parents
anymore they wouldn't do it that's most
parents
so the reason why you feel this way
is because you're so intensely selfish
so this is coming from your selfishness
and that's not a good thing that's a
character flaw why does she put it out
there in the open
um and she's being honest
well yeah maybe she's being honest about
how she feels
but she wants to fool herself and so she
puts it out there so that other people
who are also selfish can say oh i feel
the same way
and she can take solace in the fact that
there are other selfish miserable people
out there and they can form their own
little community their own support group
this this is one of the one of the great
problems with the internet by the way
is that people can take any dark twisted
thought
idea
desire that they have and they can just
go out to the internet
and find other people who who uh share
in that darkness with them
and then convince themselves that it's
not darkness at all it's perfectly
normal because they're other people
whereas in the past there's so much that
you know in the past without the
internet um
you know you probably if you felt this
way you hated being a parent
you weren't gonna go around in public
and announce that to people directly
face to face you just keep it to
yourself like you should
and you would feel alone in that feeling
and it'd be very isolating
but that's good and there would be
there'd be a stigma attached to it and
that's also good because it would it
would
maybe propel you to make the changes
that you need so you don't feel that way
anymore
because by the way yes oftentimes your
feelings are your fault
you know you have indulged in your
selfishness and so that's why you feel
this way about parenting that's on you
and of course the other problem is that
your kids are going to see that one day
so maybe something all parents should
keep in mind before you go out in public
on the internet
complaining bitterly about your kids and
how you wish you weren't a
parent your kids maybe can't read right
now but one day they will and they're
gonna see oh mom uh mom hated me
and you know here's what's gonna happen
your kids are gonna see that
and start to really realize it and in
fact even if you don't announce it on
the internet if you hate your kids and
you hate parenting
your kids eventually will come to
understand that about you
and when they come to understand it it's
going to be right around the time
when
you know they're they
they're not as challenging to have
around because young usually parents
complain like this when their kids are
younger and they have they're very needy
they have a lot of needs and you're
selfish so you don't have to meet
anybody else's needs
as kids get older and they become like
adults
now they don't have those same needs
and now it can be a lot more fun to be a
parent then you have to start having
grandkids in the mix and that's really
fun i'm told
but it's gonna be right around that time
when your kids are gonna start to look
back
and in this case now they're gonna see
the old tweets or whatever they're gonna
start reflecting they're gonna realize
oh sh this was a this was a miserable
parent who never wanted me around
and now they're knocking at my door and
saying let's have a relationship let's
bond
sorry no that's out the window now you
had the chance to bond with me and
establish that relationship through my
entire childhood you were too immersed
in your own selfishness to do it
and it's too late now
so that's what's going to happen um one
other video i want to play before we get
to reading the comments
uh here is a scene
on an elevator
that i i've encountered situations like
this on elevators but never quite to
this extent here's a man apparently this
guy tried to get on an air or i think he
was already on an elevator without a
mask on and then these two women
uh get on the elevator next and they
have masks and they're very upset that
he's not wearing one and so here's what
happens
get out get out go stop get out get out
what are you guys doing get out what are
you guys doing yeah
don't touch me don't you have to do it
get up
i'm not touching you oh did you just hit
me did
yo you need to stop
black lives matter that is so on the
nose
when i first saw that i thought is this
some kind of parody that's that is two
on the nose for these these two white
women
paranoid about koba to start while
they're trying to kick a black man off
the elevator because he's not wearing a
mess they start chanting black lives
matter apparently this is real i guess
and uh it's it's quite believable cause
like i said i've i've encountered
not not quite to that extent
but elevators have become and have been
since the start of all this sources of
this this kind of tension especially
i mean i told you it's like a year ago
where i got i had a
one one of the only times i ever got
yelled at by someone for not wearing a
mask
there's maybe been three occasions and
one of them and i think it was the first
one is when i when i got on an elevator
not wearing a mask at a hotel and the
guy was on the elevator with a mask with
his i guess was his wife
and started yelling at me get off the
elevators
you know i'm not going to get off you
can get off
and so he did and he stormed away
and there was a time early on when it
kind of felt
elevators were really uncomfortable for
that reason
because i'm not going to wear the mask
i'm not going to play the game
but now i'm getting into this enclosed
environment with this other person and
it's quiet and the elevators are already
awkward
but now we have the extra awkwardness
but then after a while you you learn to
enjoy it
because this is character building
that's how i started to look at it
get onto an elevator without a mask a
person on the other has a mask on
i know how uncomfortable i'm making them
i know it
but i started to appreciate it because
it's character building for them
you know it's it's it's
in their discomfort maybe they can start
to realize how irrational they're being
so in a way i'm doing them a favor
as this as the man in that video did so
well done let's get to the comment
twitter mob section off the handle with
rage
who's to blame
it's a sweet baby gang
[Music]
all right let's uh go to the video
comments and
dailywire.com sweet baby comments is
where you can find them
let's go to clip number one here
okay what do you call uh
let me see that video again i don't know
what happened what do you call a man who
gets himself into this predicament
let's see oh okay
is that a man do we know that's a man
behind the wheel
so the guy is wedged up on the median
strip between the two i guess he was
trying to make a left turn and he
he cut it real too way way too close and
now he's wedged on the median strip
now
i guess trying to make a point here that
bad drivers come in both
sexes but i don't see any proof that
that's a man
and of course how dare you assume is
gender
uh that's
there's no coming back from that as a
man that is a permanent revocation of
your man card and you just you'll never
ever get it back you might as well
transition at that point
uh usually i'm not in favor of that but
this is one occasion where you might as
well
and then go on jeopardy you know uh all
right let's watch the next one
all hail to the self-described handsome
and brilliant theocratic fascist
philanthropist
trans virginian best-selling lgbtq
children's author i personally identify
as a vaccinated schizophrenic trained my
pronouns are chu chu
two things first i know you cancelled
selfies but hopefully you make an
exception for these video comments
because if not then we're all in trouble
and then second would you be opposed to
the idea that cereal is actually just
breakfast soup this is one of the
greatest debates in modern society and
obviously your opinion is never wrong
about anything ever spg for life have a
great day godspeed
okay first of all there's a couple
things you got wrong here first of all
uh if you're going to respect my my
self-identification you cannot say
self-described
and then give my preferred adjectives
and pronouns
it doesn't no no
a man identifies as a woman you cannot
refer to him as self-described woman
that's deeply offensive and invalidating
to me
second
is uh cereal just breakfast soup it's
obviously not
uh shows how little you know about this
this uh subject and and food categories
cereal is a stew it's a breakfast stew
not a soup
and the difference between a stew and a
soup is that with a soup the broth is
sort of the main ingredient it's the
star of the show right with a stew it's
not the broth it's it's the it's the the
the ingredients that are within the
broth
so really the broth is just a forum for
the ingredients that you put in and when
you're eating cereal of course the
cereal is the point not the milk right
okay
let's watch one more
hey matt my name's beau from new jersey
and yes jersey is just as bad as you and
the other hosts say it is i'm getting
out of here soon but anyway i'm a speech
language pathology major and i just
wanted to give some insight on what you
were saying yesterday not only will
masks affect children in a like in cause
speech delays and speech language
disorders
it
children can't learn without facial
stimuli they need those expressions they
study your tongue they study your lips
like you said and i just have a study
fresh in my mind i forget who it's by
but there was three groups
one of toddlers who had educators and
were being taught directly one who just
had audio and just had headphones and
one that had audio but also saw videos
like toys and stuff to keep them engaged
and obviously the educated group did the
best they they had that facial
expression and not only those facial
expressions they build bonds with their
caretakers if you can't see their face
if you can't see what's making those
sounds you're not going to be able to
build the right bonds with your your
caregivers
so anyway i just wanted to throw that
out there and i love you and i love the
sweet baby gang for life
uh yeah great insight there and a great
point also at the end there about about
uh it interferes with the bond that you
need and that's that's not just a
problem for speech therapists i imagine
it's it's a special problem for speech
therapists but it's a problem
for anyone who's in a position of trying
to care for children for teachers
you know teachers that want to
if you really want your students to pay
attention to you they have to have they
have to have some kind of bond some kind
of connection with you
they have to they have to care about
what you think and what you have to say
and so there has to be some form of
connection between you and your students
and the good teachers
are the ones who are good at
establishing that kind of connection
where even students lazy students like i
was still they'll sit down they actually
want to listen to they want to hear what
you have to say because they respect you
and they feel some kind of connection
with you
and but you put masks on that's very
very hard to do it's hard to establish
any connection between people
when you're just a faceless
phantom floating around right
um going to the written comments here
joanna the artist says i'm half deaf and
it's been incredibly difficult to
understand others um as i found out that
i naturally read lips
this is a comment i've seen from many
people who are
deaf or hard of hearing
and you know it's just a it's a really
infuriating irony because we hear all
this talk
about how we have to be inclusive and uh
we don't want to be ableist and
discriminate against people who are
disabled well here is an example
of people suffering from a disability
who are actually being excluded from
society now
because they can't understand they can't
communicate
so
i would never not ironically call
anything ableism
but if you did if you were tempted to
use that term in a non-ironic way this
might be an area where you could
actually use it
and
dirty south junior says matt matt really
did try the shaming tactic of calling
men who are smart enough not to enter
into a contract their partner is
rewarded for breaking higher than 50
divorce rate initiated by the wife 80
percent of the time not real men
fyi that holds as much weight these days
as being called sexist or racist well no
one can be right about every
topic that's not exactly what i said
um if you don't want to get married i'm
not going to tell you you have to get
married
um
and it's it's
you know
i i we talked about i think it was on
backstage
recently you know is is everyone called
to be a parent and on one hand you would
say well obviously not there are people
who can't be parents
um who are you know they're just out
there because of uh
whatever physical reason they're not
able to conceive there are also people
who enter into religious life for
example i've obviously have great
respect for that
but i would still say that everyone is
called to
you know every man is called to
fatherhood in some form
and for most of us it's the traditional
kind of biological form but there are
other forms of it
one of them is going into religious life
you go and be a missionary
you know that's that's kind of a form of
fatherhood
of serving others in a kind of paternal
way
another way of putting is we're all
called to service right as men we're
called to a special kind of service
women are called to another kind of
service
even if that doesn't come all the time
in that traditional biological kind of
way
so i i would certainly say that that
holds true for for everyone
and if you end up getting not getting
married okay
there are also men who want to get
married and sadly it never ends up
happening and that's a terrible thing as
well
but nobody is called to live their
entire lives for themselves
nobody's called to serve only themselves
for their entire lives
that's not what human existence is
supposed to be and it's not gonna be a
fulfilling existence and you're not
gonna find any real joy in it
um but at any rate
what i was really referring to is the
comment from the guy yesterday
who said that uh well marriage doesn't
work it does it just doesn't work it's
not natural
making this statement for everybody
because he can't do it
and that's why i question your manhood
because that's weak
that's cowardly
if you can't do something or don't want
to or whatever
or it appears to be too challenging to
you whatever your reasons are
and so you try to fool yourself by
saying well no one can do it obviously
no one can do it and the people who are
doing it uh they all hate it they just
won't say it
that's weakness
to try to fool yourself that way
at least confront the reality that's
what a man does
because the reality is lots of men get
married
and uh and and get married successfully
i've been married for 10 years
wouldn't want it any other way my dad's
been married for 40 years
you know we're not we are not uh
outliers either
millions and millions of men throughout
history have gotten married and been
married successfully
so when you try to you know you can make
whatever decision you want in your own
life but when you try to claim oh it
doesn't work it can't happen it doesn't
work
give me a break
make your own choice don't try to put it
on the rest of us that's weakness if you
haven't seen it yet the latest episode
of adam corello's daily wire exclusive
comedy series truth yeller is streaming
now and it might be just the best one
yet adam takes uh takes on hunter biden
and is joined by comedian tj miller who
dropped some comedy gold and proves that
he's the real deal go to dailywire.com
subscribe and use code miller for 25 off
your membership and get ready for some
serious laughs
if there's anyone that the obama
administration and the mainstream media
and big pharma don't want you to hear
it's the voice of dr robert malone
malone is an american virologist
immunologist and a pioneer of mrna
vaccines who was removed from twitter
and most social media platforms for his
public skepticism of the kova 19 vaccine
and then went viral for his interview on
joe rogan's podcast in any sane society
his background would qualify him as an
expert whose opinion should be heard but
we're not living in a sane society and
so he is receiving the opposite
treatment he's being censored that's why
our very own candace owen sat down for a
three and a half hour interview with dr
malone and does not leave any stone
unturned together they touch on some of
the most alarming statistics questions
and trends that the mainstream media and
big tech don't want you to not to know
or don't want to acknowledge this is an
incredibly important interview and will
be available exclusively at
dailywire.com this tuesday february 1st
if you don't already have a dailywire
membership
join now to catch tuesday's episode of
candace premiering this tuesday at 9 00
pm eastern 8 pm central now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
ever since the infamous episode of dr
phil aired i've been forced to endure
the onslaught from an army of smug
liberal fart sniffers who though they
appear to have no understanding of even
the most basic facts of life are
nonetheless high on their own fumes and
impressed with their own intellect and
they demand that the rest of us admire
them as much as they admire themselves
now these people are quite sure that i'm
wrong and are anxious to tell me how
wrong i am yet none of them have been
able to actually explain why i'm wrong
i've had many exchanges with these types
over the past week but today for the
daily cancellation we're going to focus
on just one such interaction i think
this back and forth manages to exemplify
nearly everything that's wrong with much
of what passes for debating in modern
times it's as if this person had a
checklist of all of of all of the uh
fallacious evasive and ad hominem
tactics possible and made sure to check
every single one of them off
it's quite impressive in a certain kind
of way
so steph frosh is apparently some kind
of social media influencer type and also
she says in her bio america's gay
sweetheart as well as a phd student and
it's very obvious from her social media
presence as it'll become apparent
apparent very quickly and her response
to me that she's very proud of both
being gay and of being a phd student
indeed these two facts appear to be the
sum total of her personality and also
the source of her superiority over
everyone else on earth
now surely steph can school me easily
she's a gay woman
phd student
i'm a straight white male with one
semester of community college under my
belt how could i possibly win an
argument about sex and gender with an
authority figure such as herself
well let's see
yesterday in a reaction to one of the dr
phil clips steph tweeted quote
the fact that dr phil used his platform
to exploit two non-binary guests that he
invited on his show to discuss pronouns
by inviting a transphobic cretenous
troll on stage to mock the suffering and
oppression of trans people immediately
after is disgusting and so is he
yes dr phil should be ashamed for
exploiting these two quote non-binary
people by inviting them on a show giving
them an entire segment to themselves to
make their case unchallenged you know
and yes he did put the poor fragile
little baby deers on stage with a
transphobic cretinous troll like myself
afterwards but that was an opportunity
to shut me down to debunk my arguments
to humiliate me in front of the entire
world
they weren't able to take advantage of
the opportunity perhaps because their
entire worldview is flimsy and brittle
and can easily be broken apart like
uncooked spaghetti but they still had
the opportunity
so this was not exploitation it was
failure on their part
but i want to get into all that with
steph so instead i invited her to a stop
whining and simply define the word woman
for me
and she responded that a woman is quote
an identity derived from the arbitrary
construct of gender
or a person who would never find you
sexually appealing your choice
now there are a number of problems with
this first of all even if this statement
was valid and coherent which obviously
it isn't it still doesn't tell me
anything about what a woman is i'm not
asking where the identity comes from i'm
asking what it is
what does it mean to be that thing
this is like if i asked you to define
the word happy and you said that it's an
emotion derived from the brain
now in that case at least the statement
would be correct but it still doesn't
work as a definition of the word
because it doesn't offer any clarifying
information about the term in question
there are many emotions derived from the
brain what makes happiness distinct from
sadness or
anger similarly for women even if it is
just an arbitrary construct which it
isn't what makes it distinct from other
arbitrary constructs and also if it is
an arbitrary construct then isn't it
true to say that the statement trans
women are women is arbitrary
and if it's arbitrary how can you demand
that i believe it or accept it or affirm
it
as for the second part of the tweet we
see again the overwhelming leftist
compulsion
to sexualize everything and everyone in
every conversation no woman would ever
find me sexually appealing she says of
course how could she even make that
statement if she doesn't know what a
woman is it's like saying that no
flipperdoodle or thingaling would ever
find me attractive the word woman is
essentially nonsense after all according
to her and at any rate
one thing that these lonely weirdos
don't understand is that as a married
man
you can't hurt my feelings by calling me
unattractive or claiming that no woman
would find me attractive
the only woman whose sexual attraction i
care about is the mother of my four
children i've already got her i won the
game
even if it were true that every other
woman on earth finds me repulsive that
would only make me feel better
about having found and married the one
who doesn't
this is like going up to a guy who won
100 million dollars in the lottery and
saying oh yeah if you didn't win that
money you'd be broke
okay well i guess it's good i won the
lottery then
now i explained some of this to steph
simplifying as much as i could because i
know that phd students often struggle
with complex ideas and she responded by
retreating even further into the
intellectual fog she says quote
language as a whole is arbitrary that's
contemporary sociology 101 though i will
not be surprised if you're unfamiliar
with the subject considering classical
theory fails to grasp the concept of
change but who knows maybe you're
lacking knowledge in that field as well
now here we arrive at the inevitable
point in the conversation of this sort
where the other party begins randomly
listing college courses that she took
she can't respond to any of the points
being raised so instead she hopes to
dazzle us with her academic resume
in a subsequent tweet she claims that
she was not listing her college credits
to impress me though
perhaps that's true this could just be
the weirdest and most embarrassing form
of tourettes i've ever seen also it's
worth noting that she didn't even list
the right subjects
basic facts about language would be
linguistics 101 not contemporary
sociology 101 i've never even taken any
university courses on any subject and
yet i appear to know know them better
than she does
but what about this claim that language
is arbitrary
well um
linguistic expert over there might want
to understand that arbitrary is not the
right word here because arbitrary is
something done on a whim and not
according to any kind of system
language is a system
i think what she means to say is that
language is a construct and a convention
by the way
you know you aren't doing very well in a
debate when the guy on the other side
has to improve your argument for you
just so it's just so that he can proceed
to debunk it not a good sign
so language is a construct yeah
language is a symbol
but
the thing that a word symbolizes is not
itself a symbol or a construct so
for example the word gravity is a
construct the word is
we use that particular collection of
syllables in the english language to
denote the thing that we call gravity
but we could use any collection of
syllables there's no reason why it had
to be that particular combination in
other languages they use different
syllables
and yet gravity itself
the thing itself the actual physical
phenomenon is not a construct or a
symbol and it certainly isn't arbitrary
the sleight of hand trick that staff is
trying to pull here and that's the same
sleight of hand trick that her side
always attempts
is to conflate the word
with the thing itself
arguing that because the word woman is a
construct therefore the thing that the
word signifies is also a construct
this is the game they play with pronouns
they say hey language evolves there's
nothing wrong with calling a he is she
except that they aren't just trying to
change the language they're trying to
change our perception of the physical
reality that the language points to and
conveys
again i might be talking over the head
of the phd student so i gave her one
last chance to define the word uh what
does the word woman signify what does it
convey
i don't need any more half-baked
dissertations on the nature of language
i want to know about the thing itself
what is it
now this led to her final volley her
last attempt to evade the question while
pretending to answer it
she said quote the term has evolved
women used to be defined as property or
second-class citizens some people say
that there are people who can carry kids
but what about women who are infertile
are they suddenly men what about the
fact that the people people can be born
with the external anatomy of a female
but have the internal anatomy of a male
what if a what if a woman was assigned
female at birth presents his masculine
and doesn't have children
if that isn't a woman doesn't that
contradict your theory regarding
transgender identities
well
there is no definition there or even an
even an attempt at one
this poor girl is is paying hundreds of
thousands of dollars for an education
and after all of that schooling
she still can't answer one question from
a podcast host with a high school
diploma
no doubt she'll be crying for student
loan forgiveness in a few years as for
the point she raised infertile women are
females who suffer from medical
conditions
this does not invalidate the claim that
women are females
and and and
and also that females in principle have
the capacity to reproduce
it's also accurate to say human beings
have two lungs the fact that some human
beings have one lung doesn't mean that
we have to radically rethink our
understanding of human anatomy
i also claim that humans have two arms
if you lose one in a wood chipper
accident you haven't presented any
challenge to my claim
there is in fact a difference between
saying
humans have two arms and
every human has two arms
so there's a difference between saying
women
give birth to children
and every woman gives birth to children
you see
i'm making the former claim not the
latter
and if you can't see the distinction
then again i weep for your years wasted
in a formal in formal schooling
what about the very rare cases of
intersex birth defects well again those
are defects deformities medical
abnormalities we're able to identify
them and call them defects precisely
because we know how the human body is
supposed to work and what it's supposed
to look like
this is what's known as an exception
that proves the rule
as for steph being a shallow and
slow-witted thinker i i wish i could say
that she's the exception among college
graduates but i don't think she is
she's much closer to the norm
i'm also afraid that i must say to her
finally today
you're canceled
and that'll do it for us today and this
week next week's can be a little bit
different i'm taking a few days a few
shows off i'm going on a journey that i
can't explain right now but one day i'll
be able to tell you about it in due time
and when you do find out about it when i
can talk about it it will make a lot of
people very upset i can promise you that
so until next time
godspeed
[Music]
matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy
boehring our supervising producer is
mathis glover our technical director is
austin stevens production manager
pavovsky the show is edited by robbie
dantzler our audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is done by
cherokee heart and our production
coordinator is mckenna waters matt wall
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2022
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin